so many questions to ask you straight
off the bat what's the government advise
if you're struggling with kovat 19 and
it's affected your eyesight I'm sorry
Kay I didn't I didn't hear that question
you said what's the government advice
and then the rest of it was a bit crappy
no problem no problem if you're
struggling with kovat 19 and you think
you've got a problem with your eyesight
what is the government advice well I
think that different people will take
different steps in order to make sure
that their their eyesight is properly
addressed what's the government advice
well we advise people obviously to seek
medical advice so it's not to get in a
car and drive half an hour with your
four-year-old strapped in the back well
as we know Dominic and I know you're
alluding to Dominic was given the
all-clear by the medics he was told that
it was safe for him to return to work he
wanted to make sure before he did return
to work that he was in good condition in
order to be able to drive the long
journey back down the a1 so he took a
short journey that short journey was one
that was consistent with the medical
advice consistent with the medical
guidance when he arrived at just outside
Barnard castle he went for a very short
detail because we heard him yesterday so
you telling me that doctors told him to
take that drive he was following medical
advice I'm saying the doctors cleared
him to be able to return to work and he
was able to return to work but you said
that we should take medical advice
that's that's how you started when I
said what should we do if you think that
you've got a problem with your eyesight
and he and he did take medical advice
and was told that he could return to
work and indeed he could drive safely as
well so he didn't need to go to Barnard
castle he could have gone straight down
the motorway well I think that he was
one to make sure that he was comfortable
before driving back down to London on
the a1 and inevitably busier Road and of
course it is the case that it was part
of the national police chief's council
guidance that you could drive at that
time in order to take
exercise as well okay so you didn't need
to go to Barnard castle he could have
gone straight down the motorway he could
have done and and of course it's
perfectly possible that he might have
made that decision but I can understand
why he just wanted to make sure that he
was comfortable behind the wheel and
also as I say it was consistent with the
national police chief council guidance
what regrets do you have that a senior
government adviser took covert 19 from a
city hot spot to a rural part of the
country where he then needed to use the
services of the National Health Service
well I think the first thing to bear in
mind is that throughout it all Dominic
was concerned for the question that
would be great Mr Gove I'm sorry we only
have a limited amount of time as you
know you have other interviews to do as
well what regrets do you have that a
senior government minister at senior
government advisor took covert 19 from a
city hot spot to a rural part of the
country and then into an NHS hospital er
well again the your question which has a
number of different sub clauses to it
requires a careful answer let me give it
and that careful answer is this it was
the case that Dominic made sure that his
family unit was in a position he his
wife and his son not to infect others
and by going to a specific location in
Durham and by maintaining a social
isolation during that period they
reduced the risk of anyone else needing
to have social contact with them and
therefore the risk of the infection
spread why did his wife go to hospital
with the child and when she had covered
19 symptoms they dialed 999 when their
child was specifically ill and it was
the case that Dominic and his wife were
advised to take their son to that
hospital Dominic remained in the car
throughout and had no contact with
anyone else what was the emergency
services advised that she had the wife
had kovat 19 and she was still told
that's okay you can come into the
hospital I don't know I wasn't on that
999 call no you weren't
but we both know that that would not
have been the case don't we and we also
know that there was a nice
on standby who they had travels
specifically up to spend time with if
necessary who could have done that that
was her role that's why they went there
is that not the case
nope why not I think it's important to
stress that the niece and other family
members at all times maintained and
appropriate to social distance from the
from Dominic from Mary and their son and
it was as Dominic explained yesterday
the case that they dropped groceries
outside and made sure that the family
were supported in that way but
throughout Dominic Mary and the son
sought to ensure that they indeed did
ensure that they maintain social
distancing from their family and others
okay so they took over 19 from a hot
spot to a rural area that is a matter of
fact they subsequently took it one of
them took it into a hospital that is a
matter of fact why did they leave London
I suppose is another question you have
been framed I think you have been
friends for pushing 20 years I think how
disappointed are you that a friend of
yours was so desperate that he felt that
he had no alternative but to get into a
car at midnight with his youngster and
his sick wife and drive 260 miles and
didn't feel that he could pick up the
phone to you I would never have expected
him to have picked up the phone to me if
I had a friend who was in that position
I would be devastated if they didn't
feel that they could turn to me and I
could take groceries to their door for
them or anything else that we could do
social distancing udit you don't feel
that no I
Dominic took a decision which was to
ensure that his family was safe that he
was going to isolate from others and to
ensure that other members of his
extended family could provide him with
that support and I think that was the
the right thing to do I wouldn't have
expected Dominic to have asked me to
intervene in this way and also I think
it's important important to stress that
we don't know you know
Dominic's wife has not had covered
think so some of your earlier assertions
I'm not trying necessarily born a
peaceful and the spectator tends to
suggest that she has though doesn't it
what about his brother-in-law he looks
just around the corner I mean why did
why did he not turn to him I think
because they had their own childcare
responsibilities and also because there
were other risks as well in staying in
London looking at it in the round you
can as a number of people have
interrogate every single one of those
decisions Dominic said that it's
perfectly reasonable for people to think
that he should have acted other than as
he did of course the that's reasonable
but I'd see two things the first thing
is that a number of allegations were
made about how he behaved which we now
know to be untrue and it's also the case
that what he did was consistent with the
law consistent with the guidelines
consistent with keeping his family safe
and also critically consistent with
reducing the risk of the infection
spreading to others which number of
allegations well there were allegations
for example that he went back to Durham
you also he also heard that he'd gone to
burn our castle and we were told by
Downing Street that was campaigning
newspapers who come up with that but he
subsequently acknowledged that that he
had we've heard from the Bishop of Leeds
he tweeted on Sunday saying the question
now is do we accept being lied to
patronized and treated by OPM as mugs
the moral question is not for Cummings
it is for the Prime Minister and
ministers yourself MPs who find this
behavior acceptable what are we to teach
our children I ask as a responsible
father well I I wished the bishop well
is that all you want to say to him I
wish him well goodness are you sure
that's all you want to say to him
yes um you know I'm I'm a I'm a
Christian too and I think therefore I
have great respect for the church for
bishops for the leadership that they
exercise I wish him well before
yesterday's news conference there were
72 hours of confusion and mounting anger
from ordinary people who followed the
rules do you concede in any way shape or
form that this has been mishandled yeah
well I think all of us could look at
different aspects
and I think it's probably right okay
that if Dominic had given a full
explanation of all these events earlier
then some of the confusion that that has
arisen might not have arisen I think
that is a fair point
but I think that fundamentally now that
he has given an account all of us can
make her in mind up whether were bishops
or broadcasters about the
appropriateness of his actions but you
do feel it has been mishandled well I
don't like himself said that he
regretted that he didn't say more
earlier and of course you know there are
people who will take on the role of
commentator and that's quite right but
I'm not a media commentator I'm a
minister trying to take appropriate
actions in order to support people if
people want to make judgments about what
was and was not right in media terms
then of course that's entirely fair and
Dominic himself acknowledged that
perhaps saying more earlier might have
been better yes how appropriate was it
for him to hold a news conference in the
garden of number 10 given the special
advisors code of conduct I think that
lots of people were asking Dominic to
explain himself earlier and then when he
did there were a number of people who
criticized him who criticized him for
explaining himself in a way which was
both respectful of social distancing
rules and allowed the media to ask all
the questions that they wanted so again
it's perfectly possible to criticize
Dominic for not saying more earlier and
Dominic for having that press conference
and on attend only but it's not possible
to do is to hold both views
simultaneously I know that we are out of
time so let me ask you one very quick
question a little bit tongue-in-cheek
shops are opening again soon when is it
that I'll be able to go to Specsavers
sorry I missed that I just wondered what
I might be able to go to Specsavers well
I'll give you the number of my optician
Kay and I'm sure that they will make
sure that you have absolutely the very
best and I work maybe give it to mr.
Cummings as well it's good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us I'll let you get on